Robin when you came to LA what was the
first rule that you booked and where
were you in your life well the first job
that I ever got when I came to Los
Angeles was on a television series with
Lloyd Bridges do you remember who
because he was on Sea Hunt and and I
used to watch him as a little girl and I
I got it first of all I arrived in Los
Angeles with forty five dollars in cash
a proof sheet with headshots and a free
place to stay and I am a girl that I was
staying with her family was in the fine
art business and I needed you know she
was wonderful and I loved living with
her but I needed to be around people who
were in the show business so I had been
going to a school found a job I've said
to my teacher I'm going to find a place
in hollywood to live because my
girlfriend lived in Echo Park got a job
we got found a place with one of his
other students then got this job at this
hamburger stand then moved from
hamburger stand up to this place called
simply blues which is still I mean the
building the building still there it's
right at the corner of sunset and vine
and I had gotten a job as a cocktail
waitress and so I had back then you
didn't have cell phones and texting and
all of that you had an answering service
or your home phone and so I had gotten a
lot of guys would ask for my phone
number and and sometimes I would give
them my phone number and sometimes I
would give them my answering service
number cuz I wasn't you know I just
didn't want to hurt anybody's feelings
and it seemed too much easier than say
no and so I had gotten a call on my
answering service from this man named
row Wallerstein and I thought maybe he
was one of those Stella's you know so I
didn't in the third time he called he
said Robin this is RO Wallerstein i'm
over here at Warner Brothers Larry the
guy you used to work for a hamburger
stand handed out your picture in the
commissary and I have an audition for
you if you don't call me back the train
is going to have left the station well I
am over the moon as you can imagine and
I go to my boss and
I've just you know I've just started my
shift and i say i have this audition
it's right over the hill at Warner
Brothers you know sunset and vine Warner
Brothers right over here I can go up
Highland I'll be back before the crowd
even starts and he looks at me says if
you leave you don't got a job and I
looked at him for one unbelieving moment
untied my apron and said well I didn't
come here to be a waitress I've got to
give this a try you know and and off I
went and the part was so small that I
actually had to read another character's
lines because my character didn't have
that many lives but it was a week's work
and it was on a national television show
and it caught me my sad card and it was
great and the thing that was so
wonderful about it was that it was I had
to take it was a risk because I I don't
think I don't even know if I got I think
I didn't lose that job I think they I
did go back a little bit later and for a
little while but you know I had to take
it I had to bet on me and anybody who
comes to Hollywood is betting on
themselves you know I didn't want to be
afraid I didn't want to thank well I can
get another job as a waitress certainly
I did think that that even if I lose
this job and don't get that job I'm
going to be fine because I can always
get a job somewhere that pays the rent
so and how long have you been here I
arrived on tax day April fifteenth very
close to the time that we're doing this
interview and let's see and i got my
first job in august oh wow okay i landed
an agent by May or June I had an agent
and by august i had my first job wow wow
that's does i mean that's really quick
as a lot of people stay here a lot
longer and i just want to get back to
the whole thought about you came here
not to be a waitress or receptionist or
whatever you know fill in the blank you
know I hear from a lot of actors that
they they need these jobs obviously
because first of all it's expensive to
to be enacting two head shots and all
the things any advice for someone that
is
similar position because sure this part
time job is just to sustain them but you
took that risk you felt that you know
what this you know even though you don't
even hear a few months any advice for
people in that same kind of bet on
yourself if you have the hood spot to
come to Hollywood which is one of the
most unforgiving cities and show
business which is one of the most
unforgiving industries that exist and
you're brave enough to come to Hollywood
then keep that courage up believe in
yourself and waitressing jobs bartending
jobs those are the best jobs to get
because they are the maximum financial
return for the minimum responsibility
you know the reason I used to live in
the Bay Area like you and one of the
things that was the driving force that
had me moved to Los Angeles was I was
working in a bar at the end of sunnyvale
saratoga road called Andy Capps and and
the business of taking off it was doing
really well and I was doing theatre
around in palo alto and and the people
who own the bar offered me a small
percentage of the bar which meant that I
would have to if i took that then I
would have to be responsible and do what
you know I've taken the job and I can't
go off and just do what I want so i
thought this was my first offer of a
really straight job that had longevity
to it was you know a percentage of the
bar or betting on myself and coming to
Hollywood with $45 in a proof sheet and
I chose that because it was it was what
I wanted to do if you have a dream or a
vision of what it is that you can or
should be doing you have to follow it
you have to because the chief thing you
want to avoid at any point in your life
is regret you have to try it nothing
ventured nothing gained right yeah and I
think to anybody who's who's been around
and looking
those jobs during the recession realizes
that nowadays is what I mean I you know
it was during the recession it seemed
like you couldn't get a minimum wage job
you were in a pool you had to go on
numerous interviews you know so I think
people are so skittish nowadays and I
don't blame them i go i think is it
scary yes it can be scary but scarier
than looking for a job is putting
setting your cap for a career in
Hollywood this is hard this is a very
challenging thing and as I said if you
have the nerve to come here if you have
even a modicum of belief in your ability
to make it and any facet behind the
camera in front of the camera whatever
it may be you have to pursue it you have
to I think even scarier is is regret and
and I think some people you know they
they don't they're not there yet so they
don't see that time does fly by then and
and regret is actually the scariest
thing yes not being able to pay your
rent is very scary what regret is also
scary so well the other thing is don't
come here and rent a
three-thousand-dollar a month apartment
you know come here and no matter how old
you are get a roommate take a studio you
know live in a small place because all
of your energy has to go towards what it
is you're pursuing and and so you have
to be sensible about it you know I mean
you can't go mad with with this is one
thing that all I thought was amazing
when i move dollywood everybody spent
all this money on a car because the car
was you know you pull up to the valet
and the cars you know tell them who you
are well you're just as far away from
being a valet yourself most of the
doctors think of that sure to know
whether you might have to take a job
like that yeah so be smart about what it
is where you set yourself up how you set
yourself up your expectations count bank
on yourself not the purse you carry or
the car you drive you know believe in
yourself
you